good morning john five months
five months of using only titles that
appear in smash mouth's all-star
five months and as of this title not the
best one in the history of the channel
we have now used all of them every word
in the song like it's so
good to be done it's so good it feels
good it means nothing but regardless we
assigned value to it and now i am so
i just i'm amazed i'm proud of us we
began this
stupid idea on april 21st 2020
a moment at which we were all kind of
starting to get used to the idea that
there was a big deal occurring
and that our lives would be changed
significantly for a long period of time
it has been nice to have the constancy
of this meaningless endeavor throughout
that somewhat
difficult time this isn't just a thing
that didn't make sense it made negative
sense
it made things worse not only because
like
occasionally the creator of the work
that you are
sort of memeing on top of will do
something dumb but also because like
youtube titles matter
ask any youtube creator they think about
them a lot that's how it's one of the
main tools we have for getting people to
watch our content and
and like giving away that power it makes
no sense
no one would do that but john we were
excited about doing it for two reasons
first constraint is inspiring not like
every constraint but like adding
constraints
can actually really like juice up the
creative process so while i occasionally
hated myself for making this decision
also there were moments
that were like i can't believe that this
is such a good idea and i never would
have had that idea without this
constraint
second and more importantly i think that
we both wanted to prove to ourselves
something that we
like think that we believe but we
weren't sure that we believed
and that's that we don't want to grow
this
channel anymore like we've said it to
each other we've said it out loud but
like it's different than actually like
enacting a policy that intentionally
limits growth like i
like growing stuff but i think it's very
important to understand your goals
and how your goals inform your strategy
right
and a lot of times it's the easiest goal
to have is to grow to get better crash
courses and sideshow like that's what we
want we want to reach more people with
more stuff
so that we can educate more people and
have more people be passionate about
learning that's the goal there
the goal here is not that it's this is
about
uh creating a community there's a size
at which that
feels less real this place is a breeding
ground for ideas
for weirdness for community for change
about enabling
other things that could be big deals
like crash courses and so in a really
real way
this is more about connection and
engagement
than it is about size of audience and i
think that
after a certain size you actually get
less of those other things and how do i
know that this is really what this
channel is about well john
we gave up the ability to title our
youtube videos one of the main ways
we have of reaching audiences so an
important metric is over the last five
months
how far have we fallen not at all
no drop no drop that makes no sense
it makes it just doesn't that's how i
know that this is a different thing
that's how i know that this is special
this has been a five month long
dumb experiment that has actually taught
me
a lot and has also really inspired me
for some new
things that i think we can do together
regardless of the reasons i enjoyed it
i am ecstatic that it's over and
remarkably considering how poorly
planned this was we have
completed the project the video before
pizzamas so for the next two weeks
starting on monday john and i are going
to go back and forth making videos like
we did
back in 2007 one every weekday can't
wait
i'm very excited about it and also the
titles of those videos
are going to just be anything they could
be anything that is exciting
and terrifying john i'll see you on
tuesday